liveris bonsoir
alors eh bien vous expliquer dans votre
dernier livre à quel point des hommes
sont responsables de la dégradation de
notre planète c'est malheureusement très
convaincant et j'ai failli appeler cette
émission salut les terriens
est astrophysicien
astrophysiciens mondialement connue mais
également écologistes militants et
défenseurs des espèces en voie de
disparition
j'imagine que la lente disparition d
hubert doit vous préoccupez quand même
c'était une question alors vous dites
dans votre livre que nous sommes entrés
dans la sixième phase d'extinction
massive des espèces alors qu'il va
disparaître les chroniqueurs dans les
émissions télé d'abord je dois dire que
c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est pas mais
ce sont les spécialistes de la biologie
qui maintenant sont d'accord pour dire
que nous sommes dans une période
d'extinction massive des animaux des
plantes et que d'ici la fin du siècle on
pourrait avoir éliminé 50% des espèces
vivantes c'est terrible alors hubert je
dois vous recevoir parce que vous avez
vraiment un look d'astrophysiciens
des pins je pense que c'est le secret de
votre succès d'ailleurs non plus c'est
possible fayyad
lors des 80 non et si on compte en
années lumière ça fait combien
eh bien vous parlez de la distance oui
ça fait 80 une année-lumière vous à une
jolie peau vous connaissez bien le
système solaire vous mettez quel indice
de protection
je mets des chapeaux alors vous êtes
nunes 13 juillet 1932 à montréal au
québec oui et alors il ya une histoire
formidable si vous êtes toujours demandé
s'il n'était pas le fils de l'ami de la
famille louis marie un moine trappiste
qui était sans doute l'unique grand
amour de votre mère ils permettent pas
très sûr de ce qui s'est passé au big
bang 1
oui ça me préoccupe pas trop quoi qu'ils
soient arrivés c'est vrai nous lui
ressemblaient plutôt oui
il ya des raisons d'y penser alors ce
qui est extraordinaire avec vous c'est
que vous avez un astéroïde qui porte
votre nom il est où après y circulent
autour du soleil on avait entre mars et
jupiter il voit son tour à tour les
voisins il a une barbe à ça ça ne l'est
jamais vu et je ne verrait probablement
jamais il est petit il a 5 km d'un gros
caillou un petit astéroïde
alors hubert vous publié aux éditions du
seuil là où croît le péril croît aussi
ce qui sauve alors le pitch à l'origine
des phénomènes cosmiques naturelles ont
permis la croissance de notre planète
puis l'homme l'a peu à peu des figures
est une comment concilier la belle
histoire de l'univers et la moins belle
histoire de l'humanité
la réponse c'est le réveil vers le
réveil vers c'est une éthique qui
élargit la responsabilité humaine à la
nature tout entière exactement pour
intégrer toute la vie toute la planète
dans notre humanisme mois une nouvelle
vision de l'humanisme qui considère pas
que l'homme est spécial qu'il est le but
la création qu'il est le chef d'oeuvre
n'est qu'il doit vivre en harmonie avec
la nature sinon elle disparaîtra vous
dites mais nous respecterons entre
humains que lorsque nous respecterons
les monuments et le but c'est d'essayer
de concilier les deux et de faire quelle
intelligence humaine qui nous a permis
de survivre jusqu ici eh bien nous
permettra également de continuer à vivre
et de ne pas du tout est-ce que c'est
correct tible est-ce que c'est pas trop
tard ça on n'en sait rien il faut
surtout pas se dire que c'est trop tard
c'était la trouvez vous vous dites c'est
trop tard c'est trop tard je ne sais pas
si ce qui va se passer soit bien
personne ne connaît l'avenir de la
planète même dans 50 ans est très proche
mais pourtant je pense qu'il est très
important que nous prenions en charge
sept sauvetages de l'humanité il s'agit
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut pas trouver une autre
planète eh bien ça changerait pas grand
chose si on transporte là bas les
problèmes ah oui nous avons bien sûr
c'est pas la peine d'aller à iasi sur le
conte danse - une bêtise et je pose une
question quand on voit une étoile
filante si on fait un voeu ça marche ou
pas cela eh bien il paraît qu'il faut
une loi à davayé c'est comme l'écologie
alors c'est pas est ce que vous trouvez
qu en france on prend l'écologie dans le
bon sens dayya de tout il ya eu une
période très positif dans les années
2000 cette dernière élection avec le
grenelle de l'environnement on sentait
qu'il se passait des choses maintenant
on a l'impression que ça se termine et
qu'il faut redonner de l'espoir et
surtout de l'actif vallée et obtenir
vous avez parlé des taxes et bien
malheureusement il faudra des taxes pour
l'écologie par l'écologie si on ne la
guérit pas ça coûtera beaucoup beaucoup
pour tous plus cher que les taxes que
les taxes ça c'est difficile à entendre
on n'aime pas beaucoup entendre cela non
la taxe carbone je ces choses là mais je
crois que ces deux nationalités si on
veut continuer à habiter favorablement
cette planète ce qui veut dire en fait
c'est maintenant que les écologistes
sont au pouvoir on parle moins d'écho
logique qu'on s'était sarkozy finalement
je sais pas s'ils sont beaucoup au
pouvoir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou